foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to create view in SQL but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies and if you're a tech geek
in a continuous hunt for latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply done and without further Ado
let's get started with our one point
agenda that is how to create views in
SQL
if you are an aspiring data analyst
looking for online training and
certification from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading industry experts then search no
more simply launch professional
certification program and data analytics
from Purdue University in collaboration
with IBM should be your right choice for
more details use the link in the
description box below with that in mind
go to our PPT now how do we create a
view in Excel so it's as simple as
creating a new table the syntax is as
follows you just need to add creative
View and your customized view name as
the statements now what are the
statements statements usually have the
statements of what you query the query
statements for example selects down some
data what you want to fetch from your
table
yes I totally understand select might be
a really short one but sometimes you
might have to add some wear conditions
you might have to add some sub queries
and the entire query length might go up
to 10 to 15 lines
right now you might not be able to
execute that query for every single time
so if you create a view for that and if
you just write select that particular
View and you get all the data now let's
understand this more easily by going
through a practical demonstration on my
SQL now we are on the MySQL workbench we
are having a small database which is
flights and in that we have a table by
the name flight data and this is the
data which we have added into a flight
data right let's run this and get the
table so here you have the information
on your table about a few flights you
have the airline date of Journey
departure destination total stops
additional information etc etc right now
let's say if someone asked you to fetch
a flight from Indigo which is completely
Non-Stop
control enter now you have this right
now you face this query for once and
what if someone asks you to get this
data for 10 times a day maybe you have
10 clients who are asking for the same
information would you write this thing
for you 10 times
no right similarly here you have let's
say someone wanted to go to Delhi and
they asked you to get information for
the flights which are going to Delhi
and someone asked for the flights which
are going from Bangalore to Delhi
right similarly you have many of such
things so what would be helpful here so
let's say you add one more query
which reads as
create
View
now the customized view name could be
anything let's say View
Indigo Non-Stop
as
your query
right let's quickly execute this query
and it should create a new view for you
the new view is currently done
similarly let's try to create a new view
again
create a view let's name it View
lights
Delhi
Kolkata
and the Bangalore daily flights
right now you have the queries ready
or the views ready
now all you have to do is just get the
select statement
star from the view name
this is simpler right
it's Ctrl enter and you have the data
over there now let's say somebody asks
you to fetch the data for flights from
Bangalore to Delhi all you have to do is
Select star and you should be having the
data
there you go right as simple as that so
that's how you can create a view in SQL
and in case if you wanted to drop it
let's say you don't need it anymore so
it's simple just drop the view
and the view name let's say you want to
drop this particular View
paste it there and Ctrl enter there you
go the view got successfully dropped now
when you try to run this query you will
not get it as simple as that and with
that we have come to an end of this
session on how to create views in SQL if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require the resources like the code
we added and the PPD we used then do let
us know in the comment section below and
RTM of experts will be more than happy
to resolve all your queries at the
earliest and until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here